FRANSESC CAMPOY: Hi, and
welcome to episode number
79 of the weekly Google
Cloud Platform Podcast.
I am Francesc
Campoy and I'm here
with my colleague, Mark Mandel.
Hey Mark, how are you doing?
MARK MANDEL: I am most excellent
today, how are you doing?
FRANSESC CAMPOY:
Least excellent.
MARK MANDEL: Least excellent?
FRANSESC CAMPOY:
Least excellent.
No, I'm doing great.
Very happy that
we're going to have,
in this episode and the next
episode, one of the guests
is the same one product
manager for Container Builder
and also a product
manager for Spinnaker.
And today, we're
going to be talking
about Container Builder with him
and also one of the engineers
on the team, David Bendory.
Before that, we have the
bold things of the week.
But at the end, we
also have a question,
which is kind of cool.
It's about, like hey,
have I have GCE instances
and they're taking a little
bit too long to start.
How do I fix this?
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, performance.
How do we make this
thing happen fast?
FRANSESC CAMPOY:
Performance, yeah.
Actually, the answer
will be coming
from one of our coworkers.
So that's going to be fun.
Colt, Colt McAnlis.
But before we get into all
of these amazing cool things,
let's go with the cool
things of the week.
The first one is--
MARK MANDEL: Hard to pronounce.
FRANSESC CAMPOY:
--a new Greek word.
And the new Greek word
of the day is istio.
MARK MANDEL: Istio.
I keep saying Itsio,
but it is istio.
FRANSESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, I mix it Etsy.
So yeah, istio.
And istio is Greek for sail,
like the sail in a sail boat.
On top of that, it is
also a framework, which
is actually to run services.
It's a service mesh
for microservices.
So what does that mean?
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
and I think we're
going to have to
get them on and have
a really long chat about it.
FRANSESC CAMPOY:
We'll definitely
have a full episode with
them, I think it deserves it.
But in the meanwhile,
before we actually
talk about what it does, I think
that one of the cool things
is this.
The fact there is
a collaboration
from a lot of different actors
in the microservice community,
or industry, or whatever you
want to call it, three of them
are Google, IBM, and Lyft.
So kind of big players.
MARK MANDEL: Big
companies, yeah.
FRANSESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
and it is really cool
because the whole
idea is you want
to provide a better visibility
and monitoring and telemetry
and all that stuff
for microservices
on Kubernetes, without
modifying the code.
Which is cool.
MARK MANDEL: Which
is super cool.
I'm going to steal
a phrase that I
saw on Twitter from
Jesse Frizzell,
it is a Kubernetes
native project.
FRANSESC CAMPOY: Like,
Cloud Native, but nice,
Kubernetes Native.
MARK MANDEL: It's
I super really like it.
And at top level, it
basically gives you
visibility and control over
your microservices traffic.
So if you've ever had
a million microservices
and you're like, which
one's talking to which,
what's their status, what
are they doing, how are they
working, can I prevent
other microservices
connecting to other ones, like
doing security and control.
All those things.
That's the problem that istio
is trying to solve for you.
FRANSESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
I was always saying,
the cool thing is that you
don't need to modify anything.
The way this works is by
running a sidecar container
in your pod.
So that way, you are able
to understand everything
that goes through the network.
And it uses Zipkin,
and you can actually
plug it to things like
Prometheus and Grafana,
to actually understand
what's going on.
So--
MARK MANDEL: It's going to cool.
FRANSESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
it is pretty cool.
I sincerely thought that this
was actually a project already
part of the Cloud and
Native Computing Foundation.
Turns out it's not.
MARK MANDEL: OK.
FRANSESC CAMPOY:
I'm going to bet
this is going to
change soon, because it
feels like this is such a
perfect fit for the community.
MARK MANDEL: Maybe we
should have a podcast bet.
FRANSESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, we should--
MARK MANDEL: There you go.
I'll say it won't and
you can say it will,
and we'll see what happens.
FRANSESC CAMPOY:
I think we should
bet on when it's
going to happen,
not whether it's
going to happen.
But sure.
But yeah, we'll have a
bunch of different links
to the show notes.
Check it out.
It is a really cool thing.
I think it's kind
of early to just
run it in production
already, so I'll definitely
go check it out and see how
it can help you understand
what you're cluster is doing.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
So our second cool
thing of the week,
Cloud Source repositories.
If you haven't
used those before,
those are hosted
git repositories
that exist within your Google
Cloud Platform project--
FRANSESC CAMPOY:
And they're awesome.
MARK MANDEL: They are awesome.
They have now gone
general availability
and have been included
in our free tier as well.
So if you have less than
50 gigabytes of storage,
or up to five, what is
called project users--
so a combination of
users and project
using that Cloud Source
repository-- then
you can use it for free.
But it's all GA
now, which is great,
so it has SLAs and
stuff for your code
that's stored in there.
FRANSESC CAMPOY:
They're really cool.
We use them all the
time because, basically,
if you don't feel
comfortable pushing something
in to GitHub--
because you know, you can
have GitHub private repos,
but this one, the
good thing is that it
is something that is
private to your project
and you control who
has access through IAM.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
so considering
we're talking about
Container Builder today,
this is actually really cool
because it's all integrated
and it makes certain
things easier.
FRANSESC CAMPOY: Yeah,
basically Container Builder
is going to allow you
to be able to stuff.
That stuff normally
comes from source code.
That source code,
you could host it
somewhere on private
repo like GitHub,
and then you need some
keys to access it.
Or even easier, you just
put it in Container Builder,
on Cloud Repositories,
Cloud Source Repositories,
and then it just works.
MARK MANDEL: Yep, and it's
all on the same network.
FRANSESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, it is very cool.
The last cool thing of the week.
It is probably one
of the coolest demos
I've seen in a very long time.
It's our teammate, dear
teammate, Kelsey Hightower
at the the Pycon
Closing Keynote.
You know what he does is not
crazy, because he's like,
oh well, you deploy
a service, you
create a deployment
in Kubernetes
then you do a rolling
update to version 2
and all of these things.
Kind of normal.
But he does this with his
voice through Google Assistant.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
FRANSESC CAMPOY:
And, just, yeah.
MARK MANDEL: It's cool.
FRANSESC CAMPOY:
It blew my mind.
It is a very cool demo.
We have a link to the
video in the show notes.
Go check it out.
You might be able
to learn a lot.
It's actually a very good
introduction to Kubernetes.
If you never used it, definitely
check it out, especially
if you are a Pythonista.
But even if you know a
lot about Kubernetes,
just check the demo
out, because it's
one of the coolest demos
I've seen in a while.
MARK MANDEL: Very nice.
Well listen, why
don't we go have
a chat with
Christopher and David,
and talk to them about
Container Builder?
FRANSESC CAMPOY: Sounds good.
Let's do that.
So I'm very happy
to welcome today
David Bendory and
Christopher Sanson,
two members of the Google
Container Builder team.
Hi, how are you doing, David?
DAVID BENDORY:
Doing great thanks
for having us on the show.
FRANSESC CAMPOY: How are
you doing, Christopher?
CHRISTOPHER SANSON:
Doing great as well.
Good to be here.
FRANSESC CAMPOY: So yeah,
I'm very happy to get you
on the podcast.
We met a couple of weeks ago
when I was visiting New York.
And we got to have
an interesting lunch,
where you were telling me
a lot of really cool stuff.
So I hope that we're
going to be able to cover
all of those cool things
that you are working
on today during the episode.
But before we get into the
topic of Container Builder
and what does it actually
do, why don't you
tell us a little bit
about who are you
and what you do at Google?
DAVID BENDORY: Hi,
I'm David Bendory.
I'm one of the software
engineers behind the Google
Cloud Container Builder.
I've been at Google for
a little over two years.
This is the first project
I've worked on here
and I'm very excited about it,
because it's been successful
and a lot of fun.
FRANSESC CAMPOY: Cool.
What about you, Christopher?
CHRISTOPHER SANSON: Great.
So I'm a product manager here
at Google for Container Builder
and also Spinnaker.
We're going to build out our
continuous delivery solutions
for customers.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
All right, well why
don't we keep it simple
and start at a high level.
What, from the 40,000 foot
view, is Container Builder?
Which one of you is the best
person to answer this question?
DAVID BENDORY: That sounds
like a product question, why
don't you take it, Christopher?
CHRISTOPHER SANSON:
You answered first, I
was going to defer to you.
So Container Builder is
a cloud-hosted service
for doing builds.
And it originally, it
was created for Docker
build specifically,
so it was a way
to build Docker images
without actually having
to have Docker on your
machine, in a sort
of consistent, reliable, fast,
scalable cloud-hosted service.
And as for scarce integrations
with Google Container Registry.
So you're able to set
up build triggers.
So essentially, you make a
change to the source code,
set up a trigger, trigger
build that happens in the cloud
and then gets deposited into
a registry or artifact store.
FRANSESC CAMPOY: Cool.
The first question here is,
so Container Builder, it
builds containers?
DAVID BENDORY: It builds
anything you want.
We specifically went
after containers
as our first marketing
segment to go after.
We very much needed that as part
of our GAE and GKE offerings,
but the Container Builder
itself is very flexible.
It's configured by build steps
that I think we'll get into
and talk about a little
bit, but essentially, it
lets you build any
kind of artifact
that you want to
build in the cloud.
FRANSESC CAMPOY:
When we are talking
about building
something in the cloud,
I can't imagine, like for
instance, that use case
where you were
talking about, you
have some repo, like let's
say GitHub or Google Container
Registry--
sorry, not Google Container
Registry, Google Rece--
what is the name of the--
DAVID BENDORY: Cloud
Source Repositories.
FRANSESC CAMPOY:
Exactly, that one.
So you have some code in there,
and every single time you
do a commit, you create
a new Docker image.
But can I do this also
with local source code,
and get a local Docker
image, but with doing
all the build steps that
could be expensive somehow?
Doing that on the cloud, is
that also part of the thing?
DAVID BENDORY: Sure, so
we're fully integrated
with the Cloud SDK.
So from your gcloud command
line that you, no doubt, know
and love, you can just do a
gcloud container build submit
and take your local source,
which, presumably, hasn't yet
been submitted to a
source code repository,
you're just playing
around locally.
And you can submit that
build and know exactly how it
will build when you actually
do commit the source and upload
it to your repository somewhere.
MARK MANDEL: OK cool, is
that taking it through, say,
some automated build steps?
Or is that just
building, say, a Docker
file that I'm pushing up?
DAVID BENDORY: It
could be either.
So in the simplest use case,
you've got a Docker file
and you can use the correct
flags on the command line
to just pass that Docker
file and some source in,
and we'll just do it simple
Docker build on that.
As you get more
sophisticated, you probably
switch from a simple Docker
file to a configuration file,
we call it cloudbuild.yaml,
and that effectively
specifies a series
of build steps
that you want to run in order
to make your build happen.
And we will then execute
that build for you.
FRANSESC CAMPOY:
Those steps, I can
imagine those steps being kind
of similar to what you can
do with, let's say, Travis CI?
So is this a
continuous integration
tool, continuous
delivery, continues
deployment, continuous
[INAUDIBLE]??
CHRISTOPHER SANSON: That's
a very good question.
It's whatever people
want it to be.
So the idea is, it's not
a full CI or CD solution,
but the build step
architecture is very flexible.
Essentially, we run a container
from an image that you specify.
And so we have some
supportive build steps,
so Docker is a
good example, where
you can do a Docker build step.
But these images are--
it's bring your own image.
So users can define whatever
they want as a container that
can execute.
And so, for example, you
can run a gcloud command,
you could run a Firebase deploy.
Any tool that has a CLI you
can turn into a build step.
And people do use it
for testing as well.
So you could, conceivably, set
up a sort of a full solution,
where you trigger changes on
source, you run your tests,
you build your
artifact, you maybe
run some integration tests,
and then create your binary,
and then deploy it out.
It's kind of a little
bit DIY at this point,
in terms of using it that way.
I mean, the real
core use case is
you're ready to create
your release candidate, you
merge your code into
master, trigger a build,
and then push that out.
But, yeah, I mean it's
really interesting.
We're seeing people use
it in all sorts of ways.
They're creating Maven
builders, Gradle builders, Gulp,
sort of you name it.
DAVID BENDORY: So
these build steps,
the idea here is flexibility.
The way we solve the
problem of you not knowing
what the build chain is
going to be in the cloud
is by letting you bring
your own build chain.
So if you can put it
into a Docker container,
then we can execute
it as a build step.
So effectively, for example,
the standard Maven container
that's available on Docker hub,
can be executed as a build step
in Container Builder.
And we are seeing now our
more sophisticated users
develop their own
build steps, to do
whatever custom work that they
want to do as part of their
build.
And we are watching
the development
of a sort of ecosystem of
different kinds of builders
that are language
specific, some of which
we're going to end up officially
supporting, some of which
won't be officially
supported by our team,
but might exist
in a solution dock
or some such, that will
enable people to share
their ideas in this regard.
MARK MANDEL: So then,
that's exactly what I
was going to ask.
Is there some sort of set of
examples people should go look
at, or community
work that you've
seen that's out in the wild,
that people should go hunt
down and check out what's going
on with Container Builder?
DAVID BENDORY: Sure.
Well from our docks, we link
to our GitHub repository,
where we've open sourced
about a half a dozen
build steps that we officially
support, coming out of my team.
And those are
things like Docker,
that Christopher
already mentioned,
we've got a Bazel
build step, we've
got golanguage builders
there, a GIF builder,
so you can pull from
get or potentially
push to get as part of your
build if you want to do that.
And so in each of those build
steps, we provide examples,
and people can see
exactly what we've done,
it's all open source.
And we also have sort
of little demos there
and examples of how
to use them, in order
to encourage this kind
of experimentation
among our users.
FRANSESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So one of the
things that I think
is an amazing advantage of
using Container Builder is
that since it runs on
Google Cloud Platform,
I'm assuming integration with
other Google Cloud Platform
services, especially
authentication,
is already managed?
Am I correct?
What if I want to access the
metadata servers to download
some metadata that
I'm going to use
to access some private GitHub
repo or something like that?
Is that the case, that you just
do get and that will work, or?
DAVID BENDORY: So for
metadata services,
we've wired that access
into place for you.
We also support the
gsutil and a gcloud
build steps, one of each.
That will let you just run
command lines as part of your
build.
The authorization story is a
little bit complex right now,
we're in the process of
simplifying that for our users.
Where we're going to
land in the coming weeks
is that you will be able to set
up build permissions using IAM,
the same way you set up roles
and permissions for anything
else on your project.
So you'll effectively be
able to enable your Cloud
Builder to do whatever it
is that you want it to do.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
So let's sort of
talk practically.
Say I want to hook up a
Container Builder to maybe
a GitHub repo or a Source repo
and have it build a Docker
container at the end of it.
What does that developer
process look like?
DAVID BENDORY: So the
way that would work today
is you would go into our
UI in the cloud console
and you would follow a
series of steps there
that first set up repo
sync from your private--
I assume you're talking
about a private GitHub--
so from your private GitHub
to Cloud Source Repositories.
You could then set
up triggers on that,
so that whenever there is a
push to the branch or branches
you want, that will
trigger an automatic build,
which will run almost
immediately when
you push a change.
And then we have a lot
of users doing things
like listening to GCR
Pub/Sub event notifications
so that they know then a
new container gets pushed.
And when that new
container gets pushed,
that triggers some other step
in a continuous integration
or continuous delivery pipeline
that they want to run on Push.
You can also listen for Pub/Sub
notifications on your builds
if you want, but that will be
a little bit noisier than just
the container push.
You'll get notifications
about builds
when they start working,
you'll get build completion
notifications, whether it's
success or failure, which
is a little bit different
than just listening for what
a new container shows up,
which obviously indicates build
success.
FRANSESC CAMPOY:
So you mentioned
that the first step is to go
to the Container Builder tab
on the console.
I cannot find it.
Where is that?
DAVID BENDORY: You're Right.
I don't think I specifically
said the Container Builder tab,
but I should have
been more clear.
So everything I just described
is under the Google Container
registry.
FRANSESC CAMPOY: OK, that
makes a lot of sense.
Good.
I was like, I'm trying
to follow through,
I was like, I'm lost now.
DAVID BENDORY: I'm glad
you tried to follow
and asked, because a lot of the
listeners would have been lost.
FRANSESC CAMPOY:
So I'm wondering,
since we've been talking
a lot about build steps,
and those build steps, for me,
they're not always building.
For instance, if I had
a Go application, what
I want to do with a tool
like this is to run Lint
and to make sure
that there's no bugs,
I want to run all my unit tests
and then finally build it.
All of these things
are easily integrated
with Container Builder, but
then what about extra things?
Like let's say I want
to do integration tests
once my new image
has been created.
How easy is it to deploy it
to App Engine to a new version
and run some testings there?
Is this part of what
you try to cover,
or is this something that should
be done with a different tool?
DAVID BENDORY: So
this starts getting
into the line of where the
builder, as a component
of your continuous integration,
ends and other tools begin.
We do have users who
do some of the things
you're describing using
Container Builder.
We certainly have
users who are linting,
users who are
running unit tests,
we have users who are
playing with Docker Compose,
so that at the end
of their build,
they compose an
environment and run
some simple tests against it.
But for a really true
Integration Suite,
I think Christopher
wants to talk about one
of the other products
that we offer.
CHRISTOPHER SANSON:
Yeah, I think
when you're talking about
production level and stage
rollouts, and any sort of
reliable uptime service,
we offer Spinnaker as our
recommended continuous delivery
tool.
So as David said before,
your container builder
would build your
Docker image, push it
to a registry or some other JAR
file, artifact, what have you.
And then you would
set up Spinnaker,
to listen to the presence of
that new release candidate
and then trigger a
deployment pipeline.
FRANSESC CAMPOY:
For reference, we're
doing this backwards in time.
So by the time this
episode will be out,
the Spinnaker episode
will also be out.
So if you're interested in
knowing more about Spinnaker,
go back in time and
listen to the episode.
I think it's going to be episode
80 or something like that.
But sorry to interrupt.
CHRISTOPHER SANSON:
Well assuming
that everybody is Spinnaker
experts at this point in time,
I will say we do have a lot of
users who say, hey, you know,
this is great.
I built this thing,
and now I just
want to want to do
it GA deploy or I
want to do kube [INAUDIBLE]
deploy or something like that.
And you certainly can as
your final build step,
but I think it's more
in a sort of sandbox
or a staging environment,
where you don't really
need to have more control,
I guess, over the rollout.
MARK MANDEL: So
that's kind of cool.
I was just checking it out.
It looks like there's a free
tier still for Container
Builder.
So if I have like an open source
project or something like that,
I can take advantage of that.
Is that right?
CHRISTOPHER SANSON:
Yeah, I mean it's
a pretty generous free tier,
it's 120 free minutes a day,
build minutes, which we
see, I'm going to say,
90, 95% of our users stay under
and never even hit the paid
tier.
FRANSESC CAMPOY: So I
guess the next question is,
so since one of
the things that I
cared the most about
continuous integration tools
is that they should
be fast, right.
I am going to be doing
a new build for commit,
and what I want to make sure
is that that is done as quick
as possible, because until all
the integration has not been
run, I cannot merge my branch.
For instance, how fast
are we talking about here?
You said 120 minutes
of build time,
how many builds would that be?
DAVID BENDORY: Well of course
it depends a lot on what you're
doing in your build, right.
How big is your
build and how much IO
do you need to do in
your build and how
CPU intensive and so on.
I think I can state
that, by default,
your built is your build is run
on an n1-standard-1 instance,
so you're not getting a
huge, high power CPU there.
So we are soon going to go
public with custom VM sizes,
so that if you want to use a
bigger machine with more CPU,
you'll be able to specify that
as part of your build request,
in order to make
your build go faster.
What I can state is that
the things that are not
dependent on what
you are building,
in other words,
the things that are
under our control as the
engineers behind the product,
we have developed this
product for low latency.
So when you're
builds trigger fires,
we make a build
very, very quickly,
and we start its execution
almost immediately,
from your perspective as a user.
I can tell you that I have done
a Git merge, and by the time
I got over to the UI to
see what was happening,
the build had already completed.
It it can be that fast,
it depends, of course,
on how big your build is.
But we introduce
as little latency
into the process as
possible, as in measured
in small, single-digit
number of seconds at the most
is what we're after.
FRANSESC CAMPOY: Does that
mean that we are not actually
suffering the time it takes
to span a new instance?
Because you're
saying that you have
you're running it by default
n1, so with one core,
but spinning one of those
takes around one minute,
maybe-- yeah around one minute.
So we're not doing
that, we're just
taking less than two seconds.
DAVID BENDORY: Well I
don't want to give away
all of my secret sauce, but
I will say that you do not
have to wait for spin-up time.
FRANSESC CAMPOY:
That is amazing.
MARK MANDEL: That's super cool.
All right, I'm checking
out all the features
of Container Builder,
making sure I'm up to speed.
But I saw something
really cool in here
in that there looks
like there's a way
to query previous
builds and their status
and the details of that.
Can you sort explain
what that is,
and what people
are using that for?
It looks really interesting.
DAVID BENDORY: Sure, so we've
got a list builds API point.
If you go to the Google
Container Registry
page in the cloud
console, effectively you
will see a list of
your previous builds.
That is calling our API
point to get that list.
And then you can
filter that list
in order to query it
for the particular build
you're looking for.
So you might want to filter
it by source or by branch name
or by particular build steps or
by particular outputs, whatever
it might be that you want
to narrow that list down.
And what do people use that for?
People use this to watch their
history, among other things.
As in, oh gee, have
my builds been taking
longer over the last months?
Well let me list all of my
builds over the last month
and see how long
they took, and see
is that time going up or not,
is this the kind of query
that people are doing here.
At least those are the
ones we're aware of.
MARK MANDEL: Cool.
You, real quick, mentioned, yeah
people using this are using it.
Who are those people?
Can we talk about who
are the users, is there
any big company
we can talk about?
Do we use it internally?
Do you build Container
Builder in Container Builder?
DAVID BENDORY: So we
eat our own dog food,
we build Container Builder
in Container Builder,
and we love it.
MARK MANDEL: Oh, that's cool.
I didn't expect that
to be true, actually.
I was just kidding.
Nice.
DAVID BENDORY: So
yeah, so certainly
before you've seen it hit the
public use of Google Cloud
Container Builder,
we have already
rebuilt ourselves using it,
to make sure everything works.
CHRISTOPHER SANSON:
Yeah, I think
what we can talk about
is internal Google usage.
So the original
purpose of its creation
was to power builds
for GAE Flex and GCF.
So any time that you do an
App Engine deploy, or some
of the time when you do
a Google Cloud Function,
you are using Container
Builder under the hood,
and so it powers the
builds as part of that.
MARK MANDEL: That's cool.
So that's why deploying Cloud
Functions is actually fast,
it's like you behind
it making it faster.
CHRISTOPHER SANSON: Yeah.
So if you're an
Apogen user and you
noticed it got a little
faster a little while ago,
this was the reason.
MARK MANDEL: That is awesome.
CHRISTOPHER SANSON:
But we are seeing,
I would say that to
the two types of users
that we see very often are sort
of smaller companies or side
projects who just simply want
to automate the thing they
were doing manually before.
Like they were just,
they had their CLI
and they were creating
images and pushing it out
and they just wanted to automate
that with a build trigger.
And then, also, at
larger enterprises,
you're seeing it as
part of their toolchain.
So Alphabet companies
like Nest and Apogee
are using Container Builder
as part of their CI/CD tooling
ecosystem, for sort
of individual pieces
of their workflow.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
I think we've actually
chatted about it a bit,
but I wanted to get
into it a bit more.
It looks like there's a
bunch of triggers that
can work for builders to fire.
Obviously we talked
about source,
but is there also
triggers for like Pub/Sub
and some other things?
Is that the set of triggers
that are available?
Can you talk through
those explicitly,
so people can see how the
things get put together?
DAVID BENDORY: Sure.
So I would differentiate
between what
I'll call first
class trigger support
versus other supported trigger.
On a first-class
basis, our product
itself is tightly integrated
with Cloud Source Repositories,
to support those source
code change-based triggers.
Having said that, you
can trigger on any event
that you are able to listen for.
So, for example,
we have users that
have deployed GCF
functions, where they
listen for a base image change.
And when their
base image changes,
they kick off a build to rebuild
based on their Docker file
or based on their source
that lives somewhere,
as one example.
But anything you could
listen for on Pub/Sub
could be used as a
triggering event.
And for that matter, you
could use triggering events
that aren't on GCP at all.
CHRISTOPHER SANSON: Yeah.
For example, you could call--
I mean, there's an API as well.
So what we see clients
do who are, say,
migrating from Jenkins.
Or they like Jenkins for
their overall orchestration
for their CI
pipeline, but they're
having trouble scaling
their build execution.
Travis as well.
You can call out from those CI
systems to Container Builder,
to just run your
specific build process
in a more scalable, faster way.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
And you can also pick up on--
I think you mentioned this
briefly before as well-- you
can pick up on build
status and changes in
build statuses through
Pub/Sub as well,
stuff going to Pub/Sub.
DAVID BENDORY: Right, we
publish your build events.
So we publish-- when you create
a new build, we publish that.
When the build
status changes, when
it's queued, when
it starts working,
and finally when it finishes.
We publish all
those status changes
if you want to listen for them.
FRANSESC CAMPOY: Cool.
So integrating these
into any other system
is actually by design.
DAVID BENDORY: Yes.
CHRISTOPHER SANSON:
Sort of Slack
is the classic use
case there, people
want a Slack update
whenever their build fails,
or something.
MARK MANDEL: Awesome.
Well we are slightly running
out of time a little bit.
This sounds like an
amazing product, though.
Is there anything that
hasn't been mentioned
or you want to make
sure is mentioned
or we've missed it in any way,
shape, or form, that you want
to make sure is on the podcast?
CHRISTOPHER SANSON: Sure.
So we encourage
people to take a look.
We have a Google Container
registry tag on Stack Overflow.
We also have a Slack channel,
part of the Google Cloud
platform, it's Cloud
built. So we're
pretty active on there for
users who are asking questions.
Also check out the GitHub,
we accept flow requests
on new cloud builders.
So if you have a builder image
that you really like and want
to share with the
community, we definitely
encourage and love working
with our external users.
FRANSESC CAMPOY: Well thank
you so much for taking the time
today to tell us a little bit
about Container Builder and all
the awesome things
they can do with it.
DAVID BENDORY: Thanks for
having us, look forward
to hearing your feedback.
CHRISTOPHER SANSON:
Thanks, guys.
FRANSESC CAMPOY:
So thanks so much
to both Christopher and
David for telling us
about so many cool things you
can do with Container Builder.
I know that we might be using
it soon for the podcast.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah,
yeah, I think we might.
FRANSESC CAMPOY: Yep
which, by the way,
we're working on
actually open-sourcing
the podcast source code.
MARK MANDEL: We've only been
talking about it forever.
FRANSESC CAMPOY: Yes,
it's taken 79 episodes
to actually break it up.
But it's going to be
happening sometime soon,
so we'll let you know
when this happens.
We are actually actively
working on this, finally.
So it is time to go with
our question of the week.
And the question
of the week is, I'm
running on GCE, so have this
clustered, this auto scaling
group.
And whenever I have
more traffic coming in,
I spawn new instances.
Now the problem is that
those instances are taking
quite a long time to start.
What's going on?
MARK MANDEL: So
it really depends
on what are you doing
with those GCE instances.
We have pretty quick
startup times for IBMs.
They're pretty
consistent, we've done
lots of testing on that, that's
a big point of pride for us.
So what are you doing
after they spin up?
Usually, quite
often, people have
some kind of startup script.
Say you're spinning up a
plain old Debian instance,
you want to install
some stuff, maybe grab
some stuff off the
internet and make that run.
How do we make it so that
that part can be faster?
Because that's usually where
your bottleneck is going to be.
I'll make reference to the fact
that, yes, our friend, our dear
friend helped Colt McAnlis
wrote a really great series
on this exact problem.
We'll link to it
in the show notes.
FRANSESC CAMPOY:
Yeah, it's actually
a series on general performance
problems on clouds called
Google Cloud Performance Atlas.
Check it out, there's a
bunch of different topics.
MARK MANDEL: And what
he does in there is,
actually, he start profiling
the GCE startup script,
to see what's taking a long
time within that startup script.
But then he takes it
one extra level further,
where what he actually
does is he says, OK,
rather than having a startup
script, what we'll do
is instead build
ourselves a custom image.
So basically, we
basically take a snapshot
of the boot disk of the
machine we've pre-configured
before time, and then we can
boot that up straight away
with their managed
instance groups,
so that when it starts up,
everything is already installed
and we don't have to
go through that step
every single time for every
single instance of the machine
as it comes up.
FRANSESC CAMPOY: Yeah, the
example that he's using
is kind of a cool one, because
it's like, well you know,
this is something that
is using ImageMagick.
So the first thing you do is
you start these Linux instance
and then you install Python
and then you instant Tornado
and then you install Futures and
then you download ImageMagick.
You install it too, and then
once you're ready to go,
you start running--
MARK MANDEL: Oh wow.
Yeah.
FRANSESC CAMPOY: There's
a bunch of things.
And that takes,
according to him,
it takes around 75 seconds,
something like that.
And then he says, well instead
of doing that, let's create
a custom image.
And then the startup time
goes from around 75 seconds
to under one second.
MARK MANDEL: That's crazy.
FRANSESC CAMPOY: Actually,
it's under 20 milliseconds.
MARK MANDEL: Well,
that's the startup time.
FRANSESC CAMPOY: That's
the startup time.
Yeah, but you actually
went from crazy 75 seconds
on top of the provisioning
time to just 20 milliseconds
on top of the provisioning time.
So you're actually
gaining a lot of time.
MARK MANDEL: You're
gaining a lot of time
there, which is really cool.
FRANSESC CAMPOY: So it's
definitely worth checking out.
You're going to see,
he actually explains
how to do every single
one of those things.
There's some best practices
on how to create custom images
and he goes over them.
So definitely a very good blog
post and very good video too.
MARK MANDEL: And since we
talking about Container
Builder, you could definitely
use Container Builder
to build these images.
FRANSESC CAMPOY:
Absolutely, that's
a very good segue
between the podcast
of the question of the week.
But, yeah, absolutely.
You could create Container
Builder as we said.
You can create
containers, but also you
can create anything else.
One of those anything else
is indeed custom images.
MARK MANDEL: Excellent.
All right, Francesc,
before we wrap up today,
you up to anything fun?
Done any JustForFunc's
or anything like that?
What are you up to?
FRANSESC CAMPOY:
I finally released
the previous
JustForFunc that was
supposed to be out on
May 15th, 17th, whatever.
It finally came out.
It was on gRPC on how to
do the say command, that
allows you to say
things with your Mac,
but implementing the same
thing with service running
Kubernetes and your client
running in your machine
is communicating
to it through gRPC
MARK MANDEL: Ooh, fancy.
FRANSESC CAMPOY:
It is really cool.
I had lots of fun doing it.
And I'm working on the next
episode that will probably
be late too, because by the
time this episode comes out,
I will be in Buenos Aires--
MARK MANDEL: Oh nice.
FRANSESC CAMPOY:
--which is in Argentina,
for an event that is
happening on June 2nd.
And I want to talk a
little bit about it,
because it's kind of cool.
We're going to be doing
this Google On Board event.
It's a training
event that is free.
It's going to be in
Spanish, and it's
going to be available
all over Latin America.
We'll have a list
of all the cities
where you can go attend
the viewing parties.
I will be in Buenos
Aires, but I know
that there's many other places
where you can go watch it.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, so there
is a whole bunch of locations,
especially around North
America, from where
are we, Dallas, Austin,
Toronto, Vancouver, San
Francisco, Chicago, Los Angeles,
Atlanta, Boston, New York
City, Seattle, and Washington.
FRANSESC CAMPOY: Yeah, so all
of those are the North America.
I will be in Latin America.
And the ones for Latin America,
they will happen the same day,
so that's June 2nd.
But the main event where I will
be will be in the Luna Park
in Buenos Aires.
But you also have Ciudad Mexica,
Guadalajara, Monterrey, Bogota,
Medellin, Cali in
Columbia, Santiago, Chile,
and Lima in Peru.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
So if you're in
any of those areas,
there are lots of opportunities
to get some free Google
Platform training.
FRANSESC CAMPOY: Yeah, it's
going to be really cool.
And they're going to be
doing the live streaming.
So if you like hearing
my voice, that's
one more occasion,
opportunity to listen
to my beautiful accent.
Which I also, I will also
have an accent in Spanish,
because we'll be
in Latin America.
So it's going to be fun.
MARK MANDEL: Nice.
FRANSESC CAMPOY: What about you?
What are you up to?
MARK MANDEL: I'm going on
vacation for a few weeks, which
is super nice.
FRANSESC CAMPOY: Boo.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah I
know, it's terrible.
But I will still be here on the
podcast, so everything is fine.
But other than that, I've
got a little secret project
I'm working on with
another teammate.
But I'm not going to
mention what it is yet.
FRANSESC CAMPOY: I know what it
is, I'm very excited about it.
MARK MANDEL: Yeah, me too.
FRANSESC CAMPOY: But
it's still a secret.
Yeah, so we'll be back next
week with kind of a continuation
of this episode.
I don't know if you've heard
about Spinnaker before,
but Spinnaker is a really
cool project that kind of
goes over more things that
you can do once Container
Builder is not enough for you.
So we'll be discussing
that next week.
MARK MANDEL: Sounds good,
I'm looking forward to it.
FRANSESC CAMPOY: Thanks,
Mark, for taking the time out
of your holidays to be
here today at podcast.
MARK MANDEL: And
thank you, Fransesc,
for joining me once again.
FRANSESC CAMPOY: And thank
you all for listening.
MARK MANDEL: We'll
see you all next week.